what are you working on
uh so sam and i are going to be road
tripping out to nab sunday at 2pm mike
deep is going to ride with us road trip
our friends of gopro and our friends at
adobe were like hey you guys should
present for us and we're like okay cool
and they're like uh you know a lot about
vr right if you know a lot about vr you
can come present we'll host you guys and
we're like yeah
we know
everything and they're like okay cool
well how about you go on the main stage
monday and tuesday and tell an audience
of about a thousand people everything
you know about vr okay when we shot sync
i stole
a box of paper from my law school that
was in 2012
and we haven't ran out of paper yet and
the story about how i almost got kicked
out of law school so as you guys
probably noticed we just relaunched our
patreon campaign it's been awesome it's
really helped us make a lot of really
cool videos on our channel we've gone to
the monthly system now instead of per
video now it's going to be a little bit
easier for us to keep up with all the
rewards and also it'd be a little easier
for you guys to join us in the hangouts
and things like that because they're not
just happening all the time we'll be
able to set a more defined monthly time
for all that stuff thanks for supporting
us on patreon if you do it's been great
getting to know some of you guys and
gals kind of figured out what you guys
like what really you guys want to see
and get in exchange for helping support
our content so if you haven't actually
uh supported us on patreon definitely
recommend checking out because if
there's a time to do it this is
definitely the best time yeah i'm still
using a file that's just the default
name just new unity project oh there's
working dude [ __ ] haunted graveyard
with rain now let's see how it's raining
isn't that creepy then it's raining
well my shovel disappeared again what
the hell supposed to talk to the camera
anymore that's the new rule but now
we're doing it what's i like talking
like it's a little person like i'm
talking to
you who said you were not supposed to
talk to the camera
i did
just now
long time ago we were shooting sync
first time i'd ever produced something
of that length i was also going to law
school part-time i would leave set to
get to school and then after school i
would instead of working on law school i
would work on the production for the
next day that semester my grades were so
bad they put me on academic probation
but i had moved from my old apartment to
my new one so they sent me a letter
saying that i was on academic probation
to my old apartment i was completely
unaware of this i'm going to make a
flashlight there's nothing funny to have
a flashlight in the graveyard when
you're trying to shovel you have like
flashlight in one hand you're trying to
dig i want to have it so you can put the
flashlight in your mouth and won't
freaking hold it while you're digging
what are you gonna be digging for
you know just normal stuff
the next semester came around sync was
done so my grades went back up because i
was studying more they sent me a letter
like two months later after that
semester and they were like
congratulations you've been taking off
academic probation and you were no
longer going to be kicked out of law
school and i was just sitting at my
house like wait
what well usually the best footage is me
saying hey nico
here's here's the joke and niko laughs
and i laugh or vice versa dude i love
those joke times it's not made up but
see now i'm breaking the fourth wall
this is the fourth wall and
there it goes it's gone also you get the
awkward footage where it's like like an
interview that looks like this
yeah
yeah that's red that's right yeah ren's
like over the camera gays
i was looking at carmichael
because he always looks so hopeful i
like the camera like the house of card
style moments we're like we're talking
and it's like
oh you just looked at me
hello hello
sir i'm trying to find my manga
is the shovel there can you find it i
think the shovel fell through the world
again dang it okay there you go well
i literally have the shovel working and
then the freaking cpu exploded do you
like how it's kind of raining and stuff
we're just going over the day tomorrow
there shouldn't be any point in the day
where something is happening that you'd
have unplanned even if it's generally
relaxed and there's not a whole lot to
do you just want to make sure you go
over everything and i made this
handy-dandy pre-production booklet i
designed it in adobe indesign i'm
actually super proud of this calendar
character references wardrobe references
location photos vfx references script
shot lists
you know everything you need
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's in the ground somewhere the only
problem is that there is a wire that
connects you to the computer so what if
we made it wireless